- Say the name.
- [All] Seventeen
- Hi, we are-
- [All] Seventeen.
- We are here today to play with puppies.
- And answer your questions.
- Let's go.
- Woo.
(upbeat music)
- Hi.
- [DK] Hey.
- Hey.
(DK chuckles)
(Seventeen members laugh)
(puppy barks)
(soft music)
(soft upbeat music)
(puppy barks)
- Hey.
- Hey, buddy.
(soft bright music)
(The8 laughs)
- Come on, come on.
(puppy barks)
- Hey.
(soft bright music)
- Legend.
- [The8] Legend.
- History. (laughs)
- Legend.
(puppy barks)
(The8 barks)
(soft bright music)
- DK.
(Seventeen members laugh)
- Dino.
- Hey, DK.
- Oh, Dino. Okay.
- Dino, DK, The8.
- Belly.
- Times, Square.
- Hey, Times, Square.
- Buzz, Feed.
- Nurungji.
(soft bright music)
(puppy barks)
- Oh.
- Enjoy your life.
(Dino laughs)
- Be healthy and happy.
- Oh.
- Make your hobby.
- Hobby, hobby.
- Hobby.
- Life is short.
- Life is short. (chuckles)
- You have to, you have to
enjoy your life right now.
(soft bright music)
- R&B.
(Seventeen members laugh)
(soft upbeat music)
- "Don't Wanna Cry".
- [Mingyu] Oh, yeah.
- [DK] Hey, buddy.
- [Dino] "Pretty U".
(DK singing "Pretty U")
- Yeah.
(Seventeen members laugh)
- Buzz, Feed, come on.
- [Dino] Come on.
(beep)
(soft bright music)
- 3, 2, 1.
- Hey.
Come on, come on, come on.
Hey, hey, hey.
(DK and The8 laughs)
(soft bright music)
- No, no.
- Hey, Buzz, Feed.
(soft bright music)
(puppy barks)
(DK laughs)
- Cheers.
(soft upbeat music)
- BuzzFeed and Times Square.
- What?
- Okay.
Sorry.
(soft bright music)
(puppy barks)
- [Dino] No.
- Hey, Nurungji.
(soft bright music)
- "Future of K-Pop".
"Now of K-Pop".
(DK laughs)
- Stick, stick man.
- Stick man.
Stick girl.
(soft bright music)
- [All] Thank you BuzzFeed.
Adopt.
- Bye.
Thank you.
- Thank you.
(upbeat music)